let's go just because a lot of people
are interested in this Ark let's go to
our friend Pedro from Colombia of course
none of us believe that that's the case
but what's new what do you have for me
this week better hola mr. Baughman thank
you for taking my call you know por
supuesto oh really I really wanted to
tell you you know you know thank you for
sure and I appreciate you know all the
people on you know all the people all
the viewers would like tell me you know
I think you know oh yes you know so I
just want to tell you that you know
you're a good guy mr. Baughman and I
actually did send you up a picture of me
by the way I don't know if you've got it
yeah
Pedro sent me a drawing of a
stereotypical Mexican mariachi guy which
is a weird thing to send if you claim to
be from the South American country of
Colombia right that's an unusual thing
to send right oh you know well I want to
do send an actual picture of me but my
wife you know she well she doesn't like
that I call the show at all you know I
see and you know he got mad when I told
her you know that's a dog pedo as you
and your wife of course immigrated to
the u.s. from Colombia right oh yeah
yeah and you do you speak to her in
English that sounds unusual oh no no no
we talk in between Spanish and English
you know I'm just doing a little
impression of her so how how does your
wife tell you in Spanish that she
doesn't like you calling the show what
does she say I thought your mom do I
take back my mother honest she talked
like that I do not know it kind of it
kind of
so I didn't want to get on her bad side
you know yeah I just called my friend
from Argentina he drew a little picture
but it looks just like me it's not a
stereotype it's just what I look like
yeah because Colombia doesn't really
have the Mexican mariachi stuff you know
it's not part of the culture there oh
yeah I love Mexicans I love Mexico
I love Argentina and Ecuador okay can
you just tell me where are you actually
from well I'm in fifth now you know that
were you born where were you born
yeah I forget I forget that area another
fusion there is you can do all right
better listen you go on for oh you know
I'll call you and say hi sometime you
know I don't want to bother you I like I
like you so I like you good answers and
good gas you know you know I don't want
to bother you guys you don't want to
talk no I'd love to know where you're
really from that's what I would love to
know okay I'll remember someday all
right okay Pedro thank you for the call
very much appreciate hearing from pero a
lot of people in the audience all
wrapped up in the entire pay their arc
as it as it may be